[Music]
[Applause]
my name is joice to the group
I am the chief of the village with only mother pan
we are threatened by the miners
right loggers and we are going up
now to see the mining bringing the
distance within our indigenous area
munduruku rock pigeon
[Music]
so we know that within the
amazon also those who have forests where there
are indigenous people where they have not been directed,
we know that they don't have it, right
and that's why it's important for us to keep
the forest in  foot so that it also
gives life to humanity not only for us indigenous people it gives to everyone who is
inside the bay of this planet that we
are closing by hitting the fish reached
the goal just below
in fact given them in the rebolation scepter
inec in july  it was a party
I know so many old budgeted the re-debut of
weapons where grandson lol
the study reveals how much of the rules in ten
years
pipo hélder's goal everything wrong percent
of where the goal comes from everything everything he
called activities everything criminal  final assets
billions since the ref respect of sanford
block agree on everything regulation my name
is a method that has 19
this fight i also never intend to stop
that it has a bag and we
are not weak for a group they are a
very beautiful people and and never  let's give up
this fight, which is a ravine of the old man from
a mining since already taking some gold
is that then it will only leave
destruction behind they are already taking it already
elsewhere already here they practically
destroyed taking the gold right
they  they wanted to leave destruction
behind
warrior is the person is not you and
brave i
feel with a a person so i
am living in a world of war i always
get very sad looking at this
deforestation this sometimes i
wonder how they will not survive without
her because here is our house
my name is max in this silva has been
working here for 18 hours i started with those trapped
in the snow he stopped studying and taking care of
intern
he is easy to earn money
working h  honestly this is
what time is a gift a good month you earn a lot of
money there is time you spend
earning this is how you are working
working on your job work the
mind never knows what this fight is going to get
and everyone just suffered  too
much ends up helping my family a lot
we like this life this is how a
good life is in the environment of a forest it is good to
receive billions a month or close
again you will leave it and deforestation
further ahead is for sure you know
that  it's a forest it's a place without
deforestation but at the same time it returns
again, right, it even never dies
so one that has to forest around there
it comes back again it shouldn't be
deforested because it has the history
of the forest we have  fruit is we
survive on fruit hunting the river also
need fish
it serves common
the market for us if the prospector the
palm have the smell
these people started to deforest we
will survive that because we are
always in the bush scene and  we want
the bush to die too I think the Indian
cannot live in the middle of the
isolated forest harming the nation when
he says that the Indian has to work he
has to live like white people I agree
with him when he talks about the regularization
of mining I
also agree  because if a
region with low gold appears, there is no one in the
world who hinders the
prospector from extracting the gold, so he has to
regulate the norm for him to
reforest where he wants to devastate
and today what cannot today is the
president of the republic is  this one is about
quoting the population to kill the enemy
amp after the start of the mission only
alternative the athlete divides israel in
the gallows or sewer of the club doesn't come out
is São miguel archangel also protects us
protects us from the beautiful things
imagine we have  here you find people from
this relationship every day he told saying
deforestation eee corruption ok
police
are two sides of the same coin let's say it's
impossible for you to have the empowerment of the
cri  me anywhere in the world without
the acquiescence of the public power
I usually say public security is
deforestation the environment has to be
a state policy but it is not enough to have
a state policy
you have to implement this policy that
's the problem  from the brazilian state
of effective
the ass and honey and with a ticket in the
chinese bathroom is not that the system - here is
full of israel bank chicago cbot
week that take in the main range of the
score and give credit whose average rate of the
country that has evidence  that you who
taques said it was the same title
involves drive that four years to the
bathroom with motorboats rock biological father
and runs away to the architect but who just
wanted to give you the smallest
[Music]
sometimes yes but kobayashi is really from
lula de lula
olympic champion mil do land e china
Márcio lowest do pac Leite bruised
was entered by dress rehearsal Sérgio
Fontes dem to action climb in 2011 the
same luck but goes in the goal
[Music]
it's our task to preserve turn the game around
in this work to do in life we
r lives at risk too it's sever
l times we got in here they shot just
e careful ok look after your lives it's not w
rth an adventure it ha
a direct relationship with the  organized crime
in rio de janeiro
the factions in rio de janeiro de
sao paulo are trying to settle
here but the police are fighting
trying not to allow organized crime
to establish itself here in our
city
organized crime has reached
the poorest communities and has taken advantage  from the
misery of
inequality people generally unemployed the
level of education very low and they
recruit these people to act in the name
of crime to traffic to commit robberies
all this financed by someone or
higher echelon of the prize 16 by one
decapitated inmates would have invaded the
area of the annex  where inmates of a
rival group are
outside the despair of the
relatives of prisoners who were waiting for
news  as per what was reported he
had been charred but in the
reconnaissance it was my mother we
didn't get to see the body we saw
pictures of his tattoos right damn
robbery what i knew was that right drug and
robbery I
never knew he  murdered that he
did something like that
it got much more violent yes
walking even on the street always cautiously
always carefully
[Music]
so we use this drone
to inspect our territory
it's not because we just want it
Preserving nature is because it is
sacred, we don't even have it
for us but there is already material for the
camera or drone now but we don't
disclose our image that we do
because of the internet, right because the city is
far away
that's where  difficulty that
we have nowadays, only
you are more ahead of the government it has shown in the
area it is getting much worse, you know,
I'm also afraid, even more here
I think about my son, not even the toucan has
for them
not for me it's more for them and for my
forest for the milsinho to get together white
indian we will be like this loser and
1 of the rabbit is not a loser in this fight
time begins to ally with you
no one else will go to you land is forest we
hunt fish garimpeiro l  he just that it
is also a gain for the worker
everyone works in their area there
everyone has more in goal I told you it
has to have the legalization in case you
have the lane on the side and we are
working on that side so it won't
offend the  side of you there in working
here
so from there it belongs to you from here
for example so if there was a defendant
division divided into six areas of
you there and it belongs to those who work here
so whoever is here cannot enter there
and you from here  night, you know, this
area should also increase, so there are
pieces in which it is your area, right,
it takes the entire area after the entire
area, it's not the entire area,
practically there, so it's something with
each one
[Music]
O  ballast since they are in a way that they
don't keep they apologize and again to the
shower champions in today in china the
shanghai bag in china
the mother called to accept 2010 - it's the
jackson staff and mother of two girls sent for
spectrum of the navy of flowers
motoshow iphan space is from campinense
again organizes 0 leaving the
australian system brett hawke his fight for the
title andré garcia decided to extinguish
private individuals
[Music]
i met a person there that he is from
mato grosso i have been told he is a
fugitive right
then he  already killed two people in this
region
that's why I'm not going to
show myself anymore to them talking about
telling them that this is an indigenous land
you have to leave I can't tell
them that anymore
I could even talk about it but only that  it
's my life it gets too short
tomorrow the inter has been going for 60 years
so it worries me a lot i don't know
how to say with our future generation
will keep
and since then and until now i'm in
front of the l  uta and i will continue and i will keep
fighting as far as i could i gave
as long as i have we walk with both
legs and i'm kidding